elle a faim du crda virus vous prévoyez
que la chine restera seul debout sur le
plan économique un peu comme les états
unis à la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale d'ailleurs alors pourquoi la
chine pensez-vous date est le mieux
résisté que les autres parce que parce
que la chine n'est pas dévasté parce que
la chine est la chine a su contenir
cette épidémie parce que sur les quais
son économie est effectivement un apport
inclut un coup mais on va voir dans quel
état seront nos économies en europe
dans quel état sera l'économie
américaine à la sorte et à la sortie de
ça en espérant que la sortie vienne
vienne vienne bientôt et c'est pour ça
que j'ai utilisé ce chai en 44 quand on
fait tous les comptes le seul pays qui
apparemment pas été en guerre sur son
propre territoire d'une manière ou d'une
autre l'allemagne bien sûr envahi envahi
les autres mais après elle a été envoyée
par le par la suite à la fin de la
guerre quand on refait les comptes
les états unis représentent 75% de
l'économie mondiale je serais pas étonné
que au sortir de la crise je sais pas
l'automne si tout se passe bien quand on
fera les comptes d'une et des économies
qui sont en état de fonctionnement qu'on
ait un chiffre par le même chiffre pour
la chine que la chine représente 75 % de
l'économie mondiale je serais pas étonné
[Musique]